[Music]
this morning on the dish food blogger
and author Molly yay born in Chicago she
was attending the prestigious Julliard
School here in New York when her life
took an unexpected turn she fell in love
with a fifth generation farmer and
fellow student and ended up moving to
his family's North Dakota farm there she
started blogging about food and made a
splash winning food blog of the Year
honors from Saburo magazine she went on
to write in acclaim cookbook Molly on
the range and a week from Sunday her new
show Girl Meets farm from years on the
Food Network Molly yay congratulations
on all this great stuff thank you so
c'mon dish
thanks for have you come all the way
from Newark North Dakota you win a prize
I think you're right bird
and more importantly you put bacon in my
beverage oh yeah drink up so what have
you brought for us first of all ok so
this is like a dream brunch for me the
main course here is shakshuka which is
eggs poached in a spicy tomato sauce and
I cover it with feta and then over here
we have some kale with kales best
friends which are lots of garlic and
grilled lemon and I like to cover mine
with Parmesan and some toasted almonds
over here are some green beans with what
I call my magic sesame sauce right which
is sweet and salty and it makes
everything better and then over there
are some mini quiches with bacon and
peas and zucchini and then okay so for
dessert these are olive oil Blondie's
with chocolate frosting and my favorite
ingredient sprinkles and they're chewy
and dense and and they're kind of
healthy because they're made with olive
oil and then to drink some Bloody Marys
with harissa which is a smoky Moroccan
pepper paste so they have a little bit
of a kick tell us about the collision of
influenced you it's you influences you
have in your life because you know
you're in the you're in the Great
Northwest now but you've got agen and
Jewish influences how does that all come
together well I grew up with a lot of
carbs
I had the Chinese potstickers and
scallion pancakes and all that good
stuff and then I also had on my Jewish
side matzo balls and challah and
some of my favorite comfort foods so it
all comes together on the farm because
if I want Chinese or Jewish food I have
to make it like me don't have Zabar's
down the street so and I also there's
also like so much good food on the farm
that I've had so much fun learning about
like hot dish and cookie salad and you
have eggs for my chickens so it's just
this Wonderland of tastiness your
transition to me is so fascinating
because you were studying percussion at
Juilliard which is cool in and of itself
but then this thing happened and it
changed her life tell us about that well
I moved to New York I lived a few blocks
north of here
right in Lincoln Center and when I moved
to New York I discovered this amazing
world of food and I had this percussion
teacher there who Gordon who was super
into food and he would come to my
percussion lessons with all of these
stories about this new burger that he
tried and getting into these hard-to-get
restaurants and and I just was so
excited by that I started leaving my
practice room earlier and earlier to go
try new restaurants and and then I
started my blog when I was at school and
at first it was just supposed to be kind
of a life diary in a scrapbook and then
it quickly became clear that I only
wanted to write if I made a career out
of blogging how did that happen I okay
so when I moved to Grand Forks I didn't
really have any friends when I moved and
so I just put all of my energy into the
blog into working on photos meeting
other bloggers yeah and and you know
improving recipe development and all of
that and so over the course of the time
that I've lived in this farm area I've
been able to just make it a job and now
I work from home in my pajamas I know
that you said though it's been a tough
learning process though because there
was a lot to it from the business aspect
yeah absolutely I mean it's not one of
these careers that tons of people have
done it's not like farming like my
husband does where he's a fifth
generation farmer this is kind of a time
where vloggers are first generation
bloggers so it's not something that had
been done before so it's a lot of
learning on the go
very exciting tell us about really
quickly your new TV show farm so it's
next Sunday at 11 a.m. and it's going to
include food from all of my favorite
influences like my Jewish and Chinese
culture and the farm and it's gonna be
so much fun and there's gonna be a lot
of sprinkles - all right I love that all
right have enough sprinkle Molly yay as
you sign this dish you can hear this
meal with anyone past or present who
would it be
okay well it's Father's Day tomorrow I
was so gonna say my dad wonderful choice
chef Molly a thank you so much such a
pleasure and for more on chef Jay and
the dish head to our website at CBS this
morning calm